j'aurais accepté l'environnement avec
aussi beaucoup de fierté mais je suis
impressionné par les engagements que le
premier ministre a pris pour
l'environnement et le fait qu'il choisit
madame ben ekenna moi je vais travailler
avec eux parce que c'est un étonnant jeu
international seul un jeu mondial c'est
un enjeu qui connaît pas de frontières
les scénarios du siècle alors est-ce que
ça va être une priorité pour vous parce
qu'on sait que parmi toutes les grandes
rencontres l'acquis qui se prépare dans
les prochains jours la conférence de
paris sur le climat va être un de ces
grands rendez-vous pour justin trudeau
s'est tenu comme en est ce que vous
allez incarner le changement c'est une
priorité c'est sûr et d'ailleurs c'est
déjà un début
des carnets le changement que de dire
que c'est une priorité et paris douala
doit d'être jalon vers ça et on va tout
faire pour aînés alors il ya le climat
mais il ya beaucoup d'autres dossiers
vous au niveau des affaires
internationales quel est l'autre
priorité peut-être qu'il qui serait
l'avocat serait le premier geste que
vous aimeriez posée mais j'aimerais bien
de mettre de l'ordre un peu dans
l'économie mondiale il me semble qu'à
chaque fois qu'on se heurte au problème
par exemple la circulation des capitaux
vous avez des entreprises qui vont dans
des abris fiscaux
et puis ils font des affaires dans nos
pays mais payent pas d'impôts problème
énorme
à chaque fois on me dira mais ça c'est à
l'international que ça puisse régler
j'aimerais voir qu'est ce que le canada
pourrait faire pour que je travaille je
me disais finances viennent tous ces
dossiers mais j'espère que ce que le
canada préfère à l'international pour
mettre de l'ordre là dedans pour
protéger notre capacité je me serais
attendu à ce que vous
je sais pas je veux rétablir les ponts
peut-être avec washington parce qu'on
sait que votre patron a dit que c'était
une des principales faiblesses la dois
rien arriver si on n'a pas des relations
entre états unis je crois que les
relations que les états unis sont
essentielles les relations entre le
président et le premier ministre
pointe fondamentale et ma relation avec
mon de golog très important mais la
caisse du trio a fait c'était quand même
de dire quand qui mettait fin au rôle du
canada à l'intervention du canada contre
l'état islamique d'arrêter les frappes
aériennes
oui mais pas sans façon le rétabli a dit
oui parce que nous ne voulons pas cessé
d'être une alliée efficace dans cette
alliance
et qu'est-ce qu'elle canada va faire eh
bien nous avons constaté que tout cet
argent qu'on engouffrait pour les
frappes aériennes donné au bout du
compte que 2 % des frappeurs alors que
si on peut investir là ça dans une
expertise que le canada a davantage
travaillé sur terrain pour former les
combattants travailler pour l'aide
humanitaire
on pourrait plus utile donc notre rôle
n'est pas nous retirer
notre rôle est d'être utile pour la
coalition en vue de combattre ce fléau
terrible qu'elle ce groupe islamiste
sanglant ça c'est très important pour
nous d'aider les populations est bien
protégée et que le canada joue un rôle
qui soit vraiment efficace qui soit le
ciel si je peux retourner justement
d'autres relations qui les états unis
s'agit donc de renforcer cette relation
mais pour renforcer cette relation faut
être soi-même le canada si le canada
joue au petit états unis on sera pas
efficace
on sera pas utile non plus à notre allié
américain les américains sur notre ali
ne sont pas notre modèle il faut qu'on
soit nous mêmes pour être efficace dans
le monde
un autre dossier rapidement monsieur dix
ans sur ce sont les relations avec
l'état d'israël parce que ça aussi ça
définit les le rôle les relations
internationales depuis
dix ans du canada est ce que le canada
voit revenir à une approche plus
équilibrée dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien l'amitié au canada
et le canada israël ne devrait jamais
une affaire partisane salle jpod
d'embarrasser les autres partis en les
accusant toutes sortes de choses pour
montrer qu'on est plus pro israël y est
que cette passat monsieur trudeau va
faire du tout et l'autre chose c'est que
pour être un allié efficace pour israël
il faut aussi avoir des biens fort avec
les autres partenaires légitimes de la
région moi je suis député de
saint-laurent et le surnom de
saint-laurent cc liban si le liban ne
parvient pas à se stabiliser en quoi ça
va il dit serait c'est mauvais pour le
liban mais c'est aussi mauvais pour
israël
je crois que le canada doit renforcer
son rôle avec les alliés légitime que
nous avons dans la région si nous
voulons être un allié les gt mussig pour
israël dont qu'il n'approche un peu plus
équilibré comme une approche plus
efficace plus ouverte aux autres
réalités parce que sinon on n'est pas
utile à israël on peut dire les choses
qu'israël veut l'entendre mais pour être
utile et israël il faut être utile aussi
aux autres pays la région
j'ai nommé les banques pour nommer
d'autres avec lesquels on doit établir
d'excellentes relations et cie ont
d'autant plus important que si ces pays
la bascule comme on le voit dans la
guerre civile syrienne
qu'est ce qui va rester dans la région
comme comme capacité d'action le positif
vous parlez de la série à ce grand
dossier des migrants
justin trudeau a promis dans la mine
d'en amener 25000 des réfugiés syriens
d'ici décembre parce que ça lui tenir
cette promesse est ce que c'est possible
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
sceptiques là dessus oui on a parlé
aujourd'hui ça c'est un dossier sur
lesquels le cabinet s'est penché donc et
on va avoir le comité du cabinet qui va
travailler de façon très intense
là-dessus on va mobiliser la population
je peux donner un exemple le maire de
québec qui nous demande
qui ne dit je suis prêt emprunt un maire
courageux dans une région on aurait
tellement à voter pour nous ils sont
près tout ce qui manque ce sont des
réfugiés vêtements de courage et de
bonne volonté partout au canada dans les
provinces c'est faisable on s'y met tout
de suite on travaille très fort c'était
le premier sujet de discussion et on est
très déterminé à des de l'avant monsieur
aka cherche on administre des migrations
formidable avec john mica d'avoir
beaucoup de dynamisme et on va y aller
étape par étape mais rapidement parce
que il ya vingt-cinq mille être humain
qu'on veut accueillir et au canada on va
souhaiter bonne chance dans ce ministère
mme studio merci beaucoup